I wasn't aware that finding joy in cooking for my husband and kids
would automatically mean that I just slave away in the kitchen.
I don't have a job,
and I have a whole production team at my house making that happen.
To clarify, none of that is true.
I'm a working mom juggling all kinds of hats and responsibilities.
But cooking has always been a massive part of my life,
especially after I got diagnosed with Lupus
and my eczema started flaring up again.
I knew that I had to change the way that I ate
and the way I went about life.
With all that being said, today is a travel day.
Little whimsy Lou
and I are heading over to New York for our ninth shoot
ever since she's been born.
Try to wake up around six or seven every day,
even though that's not always that easy.
Made the kids some breakfast
while they colored and rode their scooters around the house.
And then it was time for Whimsy's first nap of the day,
while lucky and I had some breakfast
and caught up on things that we couldn't talk about the day before.
I always have to put on at least a little bit of makeup
to feel more alive, so I did that and threw on an outfit
before getting all the kids dressed and their hair combed.
This point,
I realized that I only had an hour until my car was coming to pick Me
up! So I raced over to the grocery store,
pick lucky up some essentials for when he's home alone.
Made sure to plan out the meal so he knew exactly what to make.
Lucky never lets me pack my own bags,
so he did that for me
and we said goodbye before I was on my way to the airport.
There's something about flying with a Newborn
in comparison to toddlers
that makes me feel like this is a mini vacation in itself.
Checked our bag, went through security,
and then picked up some food before boarding the plane.
Right before takeoff, whimsy fell asleep,
which gave me enough time to start the second book
of the Crescent City series.